en lançant de diane êtes sur scène vous
êtes à france inter vous êtes
chroniqueur dans le supplément de canal+
canal+
yann barthès maïtena biraben ont fait
limonier ali baddou en ce moment canal
perd plus d'animateurs que d'abonnés
j'ai l'impression
[Applaudissements]
c'est sur la scène du théâtre de
l'atelier que vous jouez actuellement
votre spectacle intitulé s'il se passe
quelque chose vous aurez ensuite en
avignon et on vous retrouve tous les
jeudis matin sur france inter et vous
êtes chroniqueur dans le supplément tous
les dimanches sur canal+ émission
présentée par ali baddou vous savez que
c'est un voyou libanais la marche avait
pas moi mais dites moi il est parti d'un
des partis à pied bien sûr mais
vincent riou avait fait le buzz
récemment avec la sphère de la cérémonie
d'ouverture du festival de cannes vous
ai décrit une vanne pour laurent lafitte
destiné à woody allen la vanne et ces
dernières années vous tournez beaucoup
en europe alors que vous n'êtes même pas
condamné pour viol aux états unis
[Applaudissements]
vous auriez dû être dans le public de
cannes devrait être vous a bien sûr
parlé de romain de polanski sauf que le
matin même le fiso woody allen dans
hollywood reporter soutenait que sa
soeur accusé son père donc ou drm
d'actes de pédophilie
j'imagine que depuis que j'étais à
donner du goût de reporter chaud et je
reçois je reçois les tweets
génial c'est une madjer l'avam
aujourd'hui plus connue de la palme d'or
si je devais objets qui alors c'est vrai
que c'est pas simple de faire marrer les
gens à cannes parce qu'ils sont là
essentiellement pour monter un escalier
et puis pour montres et les bijoux qu'on
aura prêté donc non mais c'est vrai je
pense que c'est pire que le public des
césar attention
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai dit des je t'aime
[Musique]
à
j'en
toujours
j'en ai eu des tours
[Musique]
on
va parler de lui vincent vous êtes né le
2 février 1987 à marcq ont adopté à
l'âge de 5 mois par louis françois
instituteurs et marie-jeanne éducatrice
vous dites je me souviens qu'un jour ma
mère est en train de coudre elle s'est
arrêtée elle m'a dit aux fêtes ou tard
adopté je suis très bien c'était très
petit et je me souviens de ce truc là de
ma mère en train de graphistes les fans
de raccommoder un truc et me dit ah oui
a expliqué
oui honte a adopté un ton faire rentrer
à
20h06 g est-ce que c'est ce jour là
qu'elle vous a dit que vous étiez
d'origine arabe
mais tentant cogner et elle a dit après
la dite j'ai oublié de te dire un truc
je sais plus
et attends attends 14 ans et tu seras [ __ ]
on dit au soir non je me demandais
pourquoi visite des choses et pas
sélectionné dans l'équipe de cross
maintenant on s'est compris j'ai cambrai
alors vos parents ont toujours respecté
vos origines ils vous ont jamais
raconter l'histoire des trois petits
cochons ce que
c'est assez sympa
c'est l'avenue el farès
quand vous découvrez le one man show à
l'âge de huit ans en regardant une
cassette de muriel robin et vous vous
dites c'est ça que je veux faire
homosexuels
ça donne alors
non c'est vrai vous avez flashé sur
muriel robin suis tombé raide mais raide
amoureux
j'ai fait quand on est quand on écoute
les vhs on se rend compte que les gens
n'arrêtent pas de rire il n'y a pas de
moment où c'est arrivé un truc de malade
et ça dure pas une heure quinze ça dure
2 heures 20 et en plus elle est
bouleversante
alors ce qui est vrai vous dit quand
j'étais petit dans ma chambre je jouais
à signer des autographes et j'arrivais à
la manière de muriel robin sur ça
[Musique]
le public quand vous faites votre muriel
robin dans votre chambre ce sont vos
peluche mais vous jouez pour vos peluche
trouve ça extraordinaire les aligne
comme ça je l'aimais gens mais sur des
strapontins je sais plus si je désire
des tickets m'enfin bon j'organise un
petit théâtre dans le sens bien jouent
alors ensuite vous êtes formé à l'école
nationale d'art dramatique de la comédie
de saint-etienne alors dit comme ça
évidemment spa terry mais quand tu gamme
à caen saint-etienne cellulaire
c'est broadway
et là mes enfants le destin
[Musique]
un jour par hasard vous rencontrez sur
le parvis de la gare de lyon le
professeur rollin ouais mec
extraordinaire dont j'étais fou fou fou
d'admiration j'ai passé vingt minutes à
me dire j'ose pas y aller je n'ose pas y
aller je n'ose pas y aller et je me suis
bon si tu vas pas tu es vraiment une
mauviette parce que ça c'est vraiment un
cadeau du dsce pas qui de dieu ou de
pays comme sa famille dit l'avoir mis
sur
son fils jett le fils ou là où sa soeur
aînée et et du coup j'ai pris mon
courage à deux mains je suis à l'élevage
je lui ai dit je suis en train d'écrire
un spectacle est ce que ça vous
intéresserait de le de le lire un peu et
comme c'est un grand timide françois
rollin et que comme tous les grands
timides il est très intimidant il m'a
dit ah non non non vous aider ou là
pardon pardon monsieur en bas et en fait
me dit non non je veux dire ça mais ça
me dérangerait pas
rollin vous branche avec ruquier ouais
ruquier produit votre spectacle
et c'est en voyant votre spectacle
christelle graillot qui est adam scott
chez canal+ vos remarques et là laurent
bon vous propose la bio interdite donc
dans le supplément émission l'époque de
mick hannah biraben et après d'ali
baddou on regarde à quoi ça ressemble ya
quelques années j'étais à lyon où voilà
c'est oui pourquoi je vous raconte tout
ça ah oui non oui parce que je jouais un
spectacle abba et chaque soir avant de
monter sur scène je répétait
inlassablement dans les coulisses
kosciusko morizet kosciusko morizet donc
tout le monde pensait que j'étais ou
extrêmement nerveux ou extrêmement de
droite ou les deux comme votre patron
alors que pas du tout je travaillais
juste mon articulation dis moi petit
kosciusko morizet quand des petits
kosciusko morizet ratu je veux des
petits kosciusko morizet quand tous les
petits kosciusko morizet ceux des petits
kosciusko morizet
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc grâce à vous nathalie si
aujourd'hui j'ai eu une et l'occuption
unesco pulsions une élocution absolument
irréprochable qui fera d'ailleurs dire à
louis jouvet ce garçon a de l'or dans la
bouche oui mon dentiste s'appelle louis
jouvet c'est pas de ma faute
[Applaudissements]
c'est sur la scène du théâtre de
l'atelier que vous jouez actuellement
votre spectacle intitulé s'il se passe
quelque chose c'est un autoportrait en
fête se déroule une histoire sur une
heure et demie alors vous serez cet été
à avignon mais vous serez pas dans le
nouveau film de woody allen l'année
prochain
mariage tant pis pour vous et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus